so you avoided trial by pleading guilty
yes and apologizing so you regretted it
well you know I I don't want to go too
much into that because of the motion
long story short
the experience that I had after that
those felonies were slapped on me I'm
freaking out I'm in a Cell I'm freaking
out I'm like what the hell you know God
you know show me you're with me show me
that you're hearing my prayers you know
give me a sign please I have and I had a
Bible in my hand I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna close my eyes and I'm gonna open
this Bible and I'm going to point to a
random verse with my eyes closed and I
need you to speak with me tell me you're
with me tell me that you're this is
going to be okay so I close my eyes I
open the Bible I point to a random verse
and the verse was I am yours and you are
mine I have redeemed you and called you
by name oh Jacob and that just rocked my
world because the likelihood the
statistical likelihood that that would
happen is so astronomical that my name
would be in it of all things talking
about redeeming me I'm yours you are
mine like whoa